this video is sponsored by Ray Con
earbuds so last week I uploaded my
theory as to where Zelda's powers truly
originate from and to be honest with the
amount of evidence backing all the
claims I made in that video it's
probably more truth than it is theory
and if you missed it don't you worry
I've put a link in the description below
because I'm just so thoughtful so head
on over there and check out the first
part of this mega theory but I mentioned
something in particular at the start and
end of my video that had a lot of you
either triggered or wondering what I'll
say next and that is what if Zelda's
immense show of unbridled power is the
reason for Link's death or near death
prior to his 100 years sleep and
furthermore with link immediately being
transported to the mysterious
resurrection chamber which was the tip
given to zelda by the master sword
itself that opens up a whole bunch of
questions such as how does the Master
Sword or rather fief I know about the
resurrection chamber or why was it built
in the first place for an ancient hero
that didn't need to use it or why are
their clothes and the shrine that don't
fit linked all of these questions and
more will tie into the truth behind the
shrine of resurrection so without
further ado sit back and listen into my
theory and by the way please keep in
mind that this is just a theory but
anyway listening to my theory on Link's
death and the shrine of resurrection
[Music]
so first up let's start with the most
controversial statement of them all did
link die in his and Zelda's final
cutscene together n was Zelda's
unbridled show of explosive power
responsible let's start off with the
latter
I'm gonna give you a rundown of how the
scene played out in my mind and what
makes logical sense to me when link
falls to the ground shortly before
giving up consciousness it's not until
after Zelda's blast of light has already
gone off right but what exactly happened
when Zelda's light bomb went off as I
touched on with much more in-depth
detail in the previous zelda Theory
video
Zelda's powers are related directly to
her will meaning this blast of light
that killed the surrounding Guardian
robots was essentially a wish she made
within her own mind again if you'd like
more detail regarding how this makes
sense please check out the first part of
the theory by following the link in the
description anyway the blast goes off
the machines are broken beyond repair
and we can physically see debris and
rocks flying through the air in response
to her immense show of power you're
kidding yourself if you don't think this
had an effect on link who was standing
right behind her now listen link is not
just some average good guy hero
character nah this dude has on several
occasions been proven to be nothing
short of supernatural in certain regards
in breath of the wild link can slow time
take an unlimited amount of damage just
so long as he you know has a good
night's sleep or eat some food
afterwards and all he needs is a quick
little breather before being able to
crack out as many hundred yard Sprint's
or hundred yard climbs as his hero heart
desires he has described several times
over in the journals and Diaries of the
game as being simply superhuman when it
comes to physical prowess in combat
being stated to have bested as a young
boy now with all of that in mind knowing
link is this absolute bad-to-the-bone
warrior who specializes in being able to
get right back in the fight after just a
quick breather this is entirely
debatable and speculative of course but
I don't think there's any enemy besides
Ganon himself that can defeat link he's
simply too powerful and his only
canonically recorded death was at the
hands of Ganondorf himself in ocarina
time I tend to think that his immense
fatigue shown to us in this cutscene is
due to his having just exerted himself
beating several guardian robots because
we know that if he's tired his movement
will be impaired like it is in this
cutscene until he rests up for a second
or two but if he's hurt even to the
brink of death we know that he can still
move and operate at a hundred percent
capacity because he's just that super
pain just doesn't matter to him meaning
his state of fatigue in the cutscene is
more likely due to you know fatigue than
it is due to damage now by the way I'm
not trying to say link was 100 percent
fine in the scene he definitely did
sustained some damage I mean look at his
scuff marks and scratches all over his
clothes and face but it's nothing he
wasn't already used to handling this is
the one and only link we're talking
about here don't discount him after just
a few guardians who knows what feats of
legendary strength and speed he could
have pulled off at the last second at
the very least I doubt he was already
fatally wounded before he stood up to
face the Last Guardian that's why I
personally believe that Zelda's spell
that was bound to her will that had her
mind screaming stop or halt or even just
go away before creating the blast of
light accidentally had an effect on link
as well as the Guardians and even
surrounding rocks I think she blasted
link unknowingly but then may have even
realized what she accidentally did and
that added to her grief even more so but
now to the original question did this
kill link his wounds are described
several times both in the game and in
creating a champion as being critical
meaning he was as good as dead if not
already whether or not he actually was
at this point in time though isn't that
important since either way he was a dead
man it's then that poorer and some other
members of the sheikah clan transported
the body of link to a certain ancient
mechanism enter the shrine of
resurrection real quick guys I wanted to
take a moment to thank our sponsors for
this video rake on by showing off my new
rake on earbuds that's right I the
humble mask Nintendo bandit and the
proud owner of rake ons knew every
25 year buds which are their newest and
best pair of year buds yet if they look
familiar it's probably because
celebrities like Snoop Dogg are obsessed
with them it's got six hours of play
time pairs to my phone's Bluetooth with
a single touch and has a more compact
design that gives my ears a nice
noise-isolating fit also it comes in
some new fun colors which is clearly the
most important aspect of choosing the
right earbuds what's crazy cool about
them is that even though they start at
like half the price of all the other
premium wireless earbuds out there they
sound every bit as amazing as other top
brands you know I'm a bit of an earbud
fanatic always have been really and I
absolutely adore this pair for both the
firm yet comfortable fit and their sound
quality they even come in a cute little
charging case so whether you're a runner
want to take hands-free calls or just
want to listen to some sweet tunes I
couldn't recommend raike on earbuds
anymore if you're interested in getting
a pair for yourself go to buy rake on
Comm slash mnb or click the exclusive
link in the description below for a
hearty 15% off your order
this offer is only valid for a limited
time so what are you waiting for 10,000
and 100 years ago there was a fierce
battle between the forces of the light
and the evil calamity Ganon sheikah
technology was very instrumental in this
encounter as they provided the lights
forces with Guardian robots and even the
divine beasts themselves but the
technological genius of the ancient
tribe didn't stop there there was also
excavated by Zelda's research team a
very peculiar shrine called the shrine
of resurrection which strangely held a
bed within a chamber that possessed
incredible healing properties zelda
wanders in her research journal whether
or not the shrine actually needed to be
used back in the day 10,000 years ago
and that made me wonder the same thing I
mean the story goes it was a clean
victory over calamity Ganon which means
the chosen hero of that era had no
reason to make use of its healing
properties so what they built the
chamber just in case he did one day just
in case the hero was injured enough to
be considered critical but not enough to
be actually dead I don't think so I
think the shrine served and still serves
a much greater purpose in the first
place we know the shrine of resurrection
was built specifically for the hero
himself
I mean besides the fact that there's
only one shrine of Resurrection which is
kind of weird if you consider it to be a
general use mechanism the shrine of
Resurrection is also the entrance to the
final trial that we unlock in the DLC
now why would the shaker put the
entrance in the shrine well I think we
can all agree that the shrine trials in
breadth of the wild and especially the
final trial from the DLC were meant for
the one chosen to be the hero so I
happen to think the trials were all
created to rehabilitate the hero which
would mean the location of the final
trial is no accident also this may seem
a bit too obvious but it's still a fact
either way the name is the shrine of
resurrection not the shrine of healing
or even the shrine of revival
resurrection is a much more specific
term which literally means bringing the
dead to life not metaphorically not
accidentally but specifically bringing a
dead individual or concept back to life
is known as resurrection in Japanese the
shrine is called the Chi sino hakuta
which is to say the shrine of
regeneration regenerate when used as an
adjective as it is in this case means to
be reborn or made anew I'm saying all
this because I think the sheikah were
wise to the inevitable return of
calamity Ganon and created a device that
would ensure the hero would function the
same way
placing him in stasis until his return
was necessary a little bit of insurance
if you will so I started researching
this subject and that's when I stumbled
across a very intriguing piece of design
similarity between Ganon's cocoon and
the resurrection chamber you see they
both feature the exact same style of
this tubular mass of healing properties
being fed into a single individual to
prompt their return this design
similarity is actually confirmed to be
deliberate in creating a champion on
page 223 when senior lead artist makoto
jana suit stated that the shrine of
resurrection shared its layout with the
throne room where Ganon's cocoon is and
that both were designed around the
concept of revival pretty interesting
right then there's the matter of Link's
100-year slumber in the shrine of
resurrection while apparently in a state
of comatose let me ask you this what's
the deal with taking a hundred years to
heal link I mean the longest recorded
amount of time anyone's been in a
kkoma was some 37 years and it ended up
killing the individual tragically
because the mind can't take being
inactive for that long but link was in
stasis for 100 years and came out just
fine
key word there being stasis what if it
wasn't healing link just for the sake of
healing link what if the shrine can heal
yes but its actual purpose is
sustainability or stasis because in
order to resurrect or regenerate a dead
hero and keep him on hand until calamity
Ganon's inevitable return it would need
to be able to sustain his status of
being alive right which could also be
interpreted as healing if one didn't
really understand what they were looking
at mm-hmm Zelda's research notes buckle
your seat belt guys because things are
about to get really crazy what if the
shrine was made 10,000 years ago for the
hero of that era to place him in the
resurrection chamber indefinitely
waiting for his calling to return to
save Hyrule once again clearly the hero
of that era was lost along the way
somewhere since he's no longer in the
chamber but what if the clothes that
were placed in those two chests that our
link wears at the start of the game were
actually tailored for the ancient hero
Nintendo very specifically placed these
coy little details right in the first
portion of the game that all of us did
think was weird at first but ultimately
just shrugged it off as such but think
about it all color has faded from the
clothes implying aged way over a hundred
years worth and they're distinctly a
little too small for link your first
instinct might be to think well clothes
shrink don't they but given that they've
been sealed in chests and not exposed to
any moisture this entire time
they shouldn't have shrunk at all
meaning they're still in their original
size and were simply not meant for our
link of the present time period we know
this link didn't grow in his hundred
year slumber because he can still wear
meifa Zora armor which was revealed to
us in game that she tailored to fit him
specifically 100 years ago so what in
the world are clothes that were not
meant for the current link doing in the
shrine of resurrection that was clearly
meant for a hero well to put simply I
believe they were meant for the original
hero at the time of the shrines creation
10,000 years ago that
I was just a bit smaller than this link
is all different iterations of link have
all been different heights and sizes so
this is absolutely possible
so okay I've been a little all over the
place so far and this video just keeps
getting longer and longer so let me sum
up everything I'm theorizing by simply
piecing together what I think happened
10,000 years ago in the original battle
against calamity Ganon the hero princess
and sheikah technologies were successful
in their victory and defeated the
monster for a time through a divine
revelation it was revealed to the
sheikah that Ganon would return
inevitably knowing this the sheikah
constructed the resurrection chamber and
the shrines which would serve to keep
the hero in a living stasis until the
time arose once again to defeat Ganon
then trained him up to regain his
legendary strength since the indefinite
amount of time the hero would be
inactive would surely result in a loss
of memory and therefore combat prowess
but while they were successful in
creating these working mechanisms they
were unable to enact their plans due to
the royal family driving the sheikah and
their advanced technologies away their
research and constructs and even the
hero himself were all lost to time ten
thousand years later signs of calamity
Ganon arose once again and Zelda's
research team discovered the Guardians
divine beasts shrines and the
resurrection chamber upon Ganon's return
learning from his past failures he took
control of the sheikah technologies that
were once used against him this time
leading to his impending victory when
Zelda and link were the last defenses
remaining Zelda's power was Unleashed
and link was felled in battle it is then
that the Master Sword who had knowledge
of the resurrection chamber revealed to
Zelda that link could return if placed
immediately within its care 100 years of
no brain activity left Link's mind wiped
clean of all memories leading to the
events of breath of the wild and that is
my theory regarding the true purpose of
the shrine of resurrection it makes
logical sense to me but I still don't
have an absolute answer for what
happened to the ancient hero or wise
Elda waited a hundred years to resurrect
link I do have some guesses but this
video has already gone long enough do
you have an idea let me know what you
think in the comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
this was a wild ride that I was very
excited to work on for you all if you
haven't already please be sure to
subscribe
the Bell on to make sure you're notified
of all my Nintendo content to come and
give this video a like if you enjoyed
watching as always huge thanks to my
patrons of which the amazing Brett
Harris is a new member
you guys make my day every day and if
you watching are interested in
supporting the channel and getting your
name up here at the end of each of my
videos please feel free to follow the
link in the description below also while
you're down there there's the links to
my social media pages so come on over
and say hi that's all I've got for this
mega Theory so since we're all staying
home these days go enjoy some other
theories of mine wash your hands and be
safe everyone this is masks antenna
bandit signing out peace
[Music]